hey welcome desk IJ another fun-filled
episode of random questions that I
answer for you oh yeah I asked hi J hey
hey I asked I J baby the first time
craziest thing I've ever done
you mean like crazier than getting
inside of a freezer or rolling around in
a big black duffel bag in the middle of
the street yeah I'm gonna have to say
that's that's probably at the top of my
list what's the most romantic thing that
anyone has ever done for you slow
dancing in the Apple Store dancing by
moonlight coming through the windows of
the glass on the front of the store yeah
that never happened what's my middle
name I actually don't have a middle name
does anybody else in heaven will name or
am I just a weirdo a the question what
did I want to be you and I was a kid I
wanted to be an astronaut for that ever
happened maybe I can play one in a movie
someday a video in a theme park I can
actually handle that one I went to Six
Flags not too long ago and let me tell
you that place is insane
katelyn cats dogs and dogs although my
parents have a cat I'm just definitely
allergic to it
hey Jeannie Twitter Christian Ashley do
I feel uncomfortable while I'm vlogging
in public you know it is definitely
something that you have to get used to
because people just stare at you they do
think that you're crazy and they
probably think that you have a problem
but no no you just need to simply inform
them
hey I'm vlogging here yeah but then you
know you're a vlogger that's how you
know first computer that I owned was an
Apple 2 GS and I was probably like three
at the time so don't actually remember
it that much my favorite Disney Princess
would have to be Belle from you to the
Beast love her then again I really like
a little mermaid so hmm the phone that I
had before my iPhone it was a sprint
palm tree oh it was nice they're like my
family
speaking of iPhones um have you seen the
13 EMA no-name iPhone 4 and there's an
awesome feature called FaceTime and I
facetimed with a youtuber by the name of
gesture Jim you guys should all check
him up and his video of us facetiming it
was absolutely I just seen of YouTube oh
there it is oh my goodness there it is I
don't even know what to say to you I
just was excited that we're we're
facetiming YouTube question on your
video it shows how your eyes stop big I
wanna know how you did that in the last
episode I mean a crazy thumbnail with my
eyes pretty much bulging out of my head
and it was actually really easy to do
that I just use the liquify tool in
Photoshop and I'll show you just how
easy it is to do that
let's sit for ask IJ thank you guys so
much for watching and leave me all of
your amazing questions because you guys
are hilarious
and I have something so exciting to
announce I've been nominated along with
a bunch of other youtubers for the Teen
Choice Award under the web star category
I can't thank you guys enough for
nominating me you're absolutely amazing
if you could just vote for me every day
that'd be awesome
you just go to Teen Choice Awards calm
and we're in the other category um yeah
Wow I don't even know say so